I wrote it I sent it oh you know how
people send those annoying e-blast
newsletters well I do there was someone
named let's call him chicky who sent
monthly e-blast just horsing them into
my inbox his emails included riveting
tales like took a day trip to San Diego
oh what a sunset just got a new cockapoo
named princess what's going on why do I
care about these things so in a moment
of rage and darkness I eviscerated Giggy
I went through every detail of his
enewsletter and just exploded it with
vitriol San Diego is just as boring as
you are so you deserve each other
and poor little kakapo named princess
left to live in your den of media it was
horrible I intended to send that to a
friend
just to make him laugh but instead I
replied to Giggy I felt horrible for an
entire day what have I done I haven't
heard back from Giggy I didn't really
mean all those things the next morning I
woke up and I wrote chickie and email
and just said I am so sorry
I'm a horrible person I don't really
deeply feel those things I'm clearly in
a bad spot immediately Giggy replied Oh
your first email was so mean I was sure
it was a joke
now I guess it wasn't protip best way to
get out of an e-blast be a terrible
person
you